monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la liberté d'aller et venir est
une composante fondamentale de la
liberté individuelle chacun peut
circuler sur l'ensemble du territoire
national dès lors qu'il y ait
régulièrement entre et or voilà
maintenant plus d'un mois que la sncf et
la ratp ne sont plus en capacité
d'assurer normalement leur mission de
service public avec bruno retailleau et
de très nombreux collègues nous
proposons la création d'un véritable
service minimum de transport garanties
applicables à l'ensemble des transports
publics
ce service minimum garanti ne remet pas
en cause le droit de grève
il propose simplement d'aménager son
exercice à l'instar de ce que prévoit
déjà la loi pour d'autres services
publics comme les hôpitaux ou la
télévision du public
il s'inscrit clairement dans une
jurisprudence bien établie du conseil
constitutionnel mais ce n'est pas tout
cette proposition de loi prévoit
également de simplifier les démarches
des usagers dont le voyage est annulé
afin qu'ils ne soient plus pénalisés
financièrement
elle interdit en effet l'avoir
actuellement scandaleusement mis en
place au profit d'un remboursement
direct notons d'ailleurs au passage que
la sncf est plus à l'aise avec le
siphonnage de nos cartes bleues qu'avec
le respect de ses horaires j'ajoute
enfin que valérie pécresse présidente de
la région ile de france demande à juste
titre depuis plusieurs semaines et dans
le même esprit le remboursement intégral
du passe navigo pour tous les jours de
grève
monsieur le ministre il est de votre
responsabilité de prendre les mesures
qui s'imposent pour en finir avec
l'insupportable triptyque pagaille
raquette et escroquerie que comptez vous
faire concrètement
[Applaudissements]